Hi everyone.
I'm just back for the second module where we're gonna go over internal structure.
You guys have probably seen that in the first
module it's split in two parts because the video
broke up halfway through on the first recording so I just recorded the final
part and put it as a part two. So you got the swing structure
part one, swing structure part two. Now,
we're gonna go over internal structure and,
you know, I basically went over a little bit of it in the first
module but it's quite simple. You know, a lot of people get swing,
internal, fret, all confused, right?
I've seen many times and spoken to many people that think swing structure is
done on a higher time frame and internal structure is done on a lower
time frame, but that's not the case.
You have swing structure, which are your swing points,
which we just went over, and then inside of those swing points you have
what we call a range, okay? So,
you can see here, we have our swing low, and our swing high here,
and we have our swing high up here. From this swing low to this
swing high is our range. So, if we do the box method,
like I mentioned in YouTube videos,
or like is mentioned in the previous one, and drag that across, anything from,
you know, anything inside of this
low and high is internal. So,
this is what we call internal structure. Now, the indicator plays internal structure out
in between ranges until the range changes.
So, when this, uh,
when price breaks, either the high or the low,
this internal structure will disappear, and then we'll have new swing points,
and then when new internal structure starts again, you'll have internal structure.
But how can we use internal structure?
Well, it's pretty simple. You know,
especially if you're somebody that likes to trade internally.
Now, which you don't really, I don't look to trade internal,
it's just good to know what's actually happening internally.
I use swing points on 4 hour,
15 minute, and 1 minute. So I use my 1 minute to realign myself.
But sometimes I use internal. And that's I use internal in a situation like
this. You know, I can see very clearly here that we have a very
large range. So,
when price pulled back into this range,
you can see here, what you want to do is internally you want to
look for your shift to realign yourself with the future.
So, because we had a change of character to the upside,
we're bullish on the 15. So, internally,
right now we're bearish. You know, we've got a internal low,
internal low or high, internal low or low,
internal low or high, internal low or low, internal low or high,
internal low or low. Okay? Then,
price reverses from here, trades to the upside,
breaking this internal high, causing an internal change of character.
It's just an internal change of character. Now,
you could, as you would see here though,
you'd actually get stopped out, right? You could then look to come down a
and take a position here. But this is the key part that,
like I said a moment ago, right? Why would I not take this immediately?
Because I'm still on the 15 minute. What I would do is I would
come down to the 1 minute. Then when price starts to get into this
area, I use my 1 minute to realign myself.
From what I can see here though, it looks like it'd be one of
those positions where you'd get stopped out anyway. But what this has done,
this internal change of character, is,
if you think about it now but looking at it in a bigger picture.
I know I've had a change of character to the upside.
So, I'm Bullish, I've now had a full pullback into this range,
pulled quite deep into the range, and I've had an internal change of character.
Yes, you would've took a position here and got wicked out,
but that's still shown us that the internal structure has now shifted.
Bullish also. So even what's been the case,
is that the internal structure
has shifted.
You look for your shift, and you take this position,
to the upside. It's quite simple. You know,
these modules are short, they're simple.
You know, if you have questions, make sure you let me know, but there's
nothing too difficult to explain, because you don't have to manually do this.
You don't have to manually understand how to mark swing and internal
structure. What you need to do now is understand what it is,
and just follow the indicator, because it's done for you.
If you have any questions, let me know. I'll give you a little quick
run-down again. Internal structure is the structure that's inside of your swing
points. So you swing low, swing high is the range,
internal. All of this is internal structure, and you will know that because it
will say I. It will say I before.
Internal low, internal low or high. Internal brake structure,
internal low or low, internal low or high, internal brake structure,
internal change of character, internal higher high,
because it's higher than the previous internal high, and et cetera.
It's pretty simple, pretty straightforward.
And yeah, any questions let me know.